From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay. One and action.
Today is Saturday March 9, 2013. My name is Dr. Hasan Kwame Jeffries of the Ohio State University and the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with videographer Pete Daniel in Albany, Georgia on the campus of Albany State University to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here with Mr. Sam Mahon. Thank you so much for being here with us.
I want to begin simply by asking you when and where were you born?
It was born in Americus, Georgia which is Sumter County, Southwest Georgia.
And what year? Was it the date of birth? 1945.
1945. So the war is over.
Some people say that World War II usher in this sort of new era of transformation and democracy. What was America's light when you were growing up?
I imagine it was like most small southern rural cities in that the lines of separation were very, very vivid, very stark.
As a child growing up, you tended to try to enjoy your childhood but there were instances where you just knew that things just were not right.
And a lot of that came about when you would look at your parents and see how they reacted to situations when white people were present.
You notice little subtle things like you look at your father and your mother and you notice how there's virtually no eye contact when they are talking and speaking with white people.
Your father is always looking in a downward manner. Is it that eye contact with somehow create a confrontation?
You notice other things like how your community for instance, the old saying about across the railroad tracks was very true.
No sidewalks, the roads were dirt at that time, no pavement anywhere. I grew up with an outdoor toilet. We had an outdoor toilet. We didn't get plumbing until I was a senior in high school.
My mother was a domestic worker. She worked in white people's home. That's what she did as employment. My father was a factory worker who worked in a basket factory that produced baskets to contain (the) fruit, large shipments of fruit.
But what were their names?
My father's name was Bergen Mahon. My mother's name was Lula Bell. My maiden name was Walker.
I was a seventh of six children. I was a sixth. I had a sister that younger than myself.
Other things that you pick up on like for instance, when you're totally dependent on white stuff for their services, for instance, there was always the...
There was what we call the policy man, the insurance agent who would come to do it or do other industries to collect the money for the policies.
They would simply come up to your house and not even knock and just simply walk into your house. That's how white agents.
That's how much they took liberty. That's how much they went control.
So of your everyday existence you saw these things. But it didn't really manage best in terms of you as a child, you know you accepted these things.
And of course, anytime you left the house your parents would always tell you, you knew your place, you knew what you could do and what you couldn't do.
And it was out of fear for your life that they did these things. So you grew up under those circumstances.
But I have to say that even though you internalize these things, it was something that you didn't really resist. You went along with it.
It was only until I became engaged in what was called. There was a group of ministers who would start a voter registration project called the Americus Voters League.
This was prior to any civil rights organizations coming to America. And I was probably in the 10th grade or something like that.
And began to work in terms of trying to talk to other students about voter registration and those kinds of things.
To you about 16? Yeah, about 1916-1961.
Exactly. And these are students in your high school? Yeah, exactly. And what did you go to school?
I graduated some of the county high school in Americus, Georgia. I went through the entire school system there and went from schools that had the old pot-bellied pot-bellied wood stoves and until finally getting air-conditioned schools when I finally graduated from school.
So you become involved with this voter league? Yeah. And what led you to become involved with them?
I think it was more out of having something to do, I think. In fact, that's what led me to become more of an activist later on.
It was in a small town. You had very little outlets in terms of trying to do things that were outside of the norm.
And so anything that had a sense of being something different or then I was attracted to that.
How did your classmates respond to you when you start talking to them about some of the things that you're doing with the voter league?
Well, some of them responded quite positively. And then those that did took it as a challenge.
And there was a very short time between that time and when SNCC came into the records. And so that further galvanized those people who had been receptive in the first place.
And so it was at that time that we sort of moved from that right into that activism within the movement, which later became America's movement.
Did your parents, what did they think about your early involvement, even before Snick gets there?
My parents were mainly disengaged. And I think a lot of it had to do. My father was a working man. He had very little conversation and he just worked.
My mom, as a domestic, was more receptive to conversation. She had no particular feelings about it.
But there was very little conversation in terms of what I was doing in terms of that kind of work and what happened.
But they were not against it. They were very supportive. And what I did, they were of course always fearful. But especially my father, who, but my mother was, she had fears also, but she was more likely to pull along with the things that I was doing at that time.
How about your siblings?
By that time, all the siblings were away from home. During this time, it was myself and my younger sister, who was three years younger.
And of course, she was not involved because she got pregnant before she finished school and moved away to Florida and started a family.
And so I was virtually left there, all my older brothers had joined the military, we're in service. And so there was very little interaction between me and my other siblings at that time.
In fact, many of them know that I was involved in this until years later. I mean, they just didn't pay attention to what the things that was happening at my time.
So in this interim period between you start and you get your feet wet, you're beginning to become sort of publicly active.
And so are there other things that you're doing as well with the voters lead before you encounter a SNCC folk?
No, not at all. Just really going to school and trying to manipulate through that, some things that kids normally do in that period.
I worked outside jobs, I picked cotton. Before school opened up, I pulled up peanuts, I picked peaches, you know, you name it in field work.
And then also as a student in school, I got a job working at a clothing store, cleaning up and what have you.
So I did the normal things that kids do at that time. If you can get a job, you know, then that's where I did.
What was some of, or when did you become engaged with SNCC?
Stick came into America's in late 1962. Don Harris, John Perdew, Ralph Allen, I believe, the first work to came in.
They were dispatched there from here, from Albany, by a project director, Charles Sherrod.
And at the time they were expanding their work in several counties around throughout the southern border area.
America was chosen because of the demographics and the dynamics there. And most of these rural counties blacks comprised full of 50% of the population.
median income was about $1200 a year for blacks, you know, and it was maybe tripled that for white school, four or five times after white school.
Schools of course were a second class. I never got a new book at all throughout the 12 years of school.
We always had books passed on to us. We knew that, you know how you got a book in school in the next class and you'd have all these names written into the books, you know.
So we knew as students that we were two or three years behind in terms of the books that we received.
But we had not your teachers at that time who cared for us. And we did the best they could with what they had.
And so we we cherish that. To the state we cherish that because they laid the ground was first to do the work that I feel that I began doing later on.
You're still in high school at the time. What do you think about these freedom writers that so many people call them?
As I said, anything that was new to a kid, one of the smaller town was exciting, interesting.
They came into America's. They had Northern dialects, you know, they were from college campuses. They bought books with them. Books that I had never seen before.
They set up what was called a SNCC house where they moved into these houses and immediately began to reach out to students and the pastors and ministers really could to begin to try and build workers to work on voter registration.
So the SNCC house became a hangout house for kids, you know, we would go there and we began doing things like printing leaflets and flyers on the old mimeograph machines and hand-crank machines.
And the fact that they introduced us to black authors, you know, Richard Wright, James Baldwin, you know, the boy and all these people that we hadn't heard of gave us a whole sense of meaning, you know, and being, you know, and as a kid, it really, it really sparked an interest in us and made us want to come back to that house every day after school.
You know, see what they had to do, they wanted us to do for them, you know, so that's literally how it started, you know.
And what, what, what was the freedom house?
It would be a rental house, an old wood frame house, shotgun house that some might have read to them, you know, for little nothing.
It may have made out of head running water, you know, but it was just a meeting house and they slept there sometimes on the floor, sleeping bags, what happened, you know.
And so I even wound up spending the night there, you know, just hanging out at the SNCC house.
And that's how my activism began.
And the more I stayed there, the more my interest increased. And the more I recognized the duality of this system that we lived in, and that there was a chance it was up in the batter.
How did you get involved with the protest that the movie did?
We spent several months working on voter registration. We would canvas door to door through advocacy, and not only in the city, but we went out to the counties also.
And this is an anniversary.
Is it an anniversary for this? 63?
Yes, okay.
We recognized, and through SNCC made us recognize that the only way to form the power, the change in the dynamics of the system, was through getting people registered, choosing our own candidates, looking them to office, who would look after our own interests before change.
So it was going to be a time to recognize that voting was power. And so we spent our days, and even as a record on voter registration, we would go to the house to house.
We would take down names.
We would schedule times, and we could come back and pick them up to take them down the register.
We set up Freedom School, because we were talking about people who some who could not read or write, some who had mostly had never voted.
And so the Freedom Houses were places where we would organize, and teach people how to read and write, or at least pass the exams, the literacy test at that time.
It was a place of organizing, strategy, and what have you, what neighborhoods we would canvas, who would drive the cars to take them down.
It was also a place where we would taught each other, self defense techniques, not fighting back because we had accepted the principle of nonviolence.
But basically teaching us how to protect ourselves, and we were attacked, if we were attacked, how to curl up in a fetal position if you were beaten and kicked and what have you.
We would go through these scenarios of how if someone spat in your face, you know, how would you respond, and just prepare us for what we knew eventually was going to come.
And that they came?
That they came, we eventually moved from voter registration to begin and to test the laws of public accommodation.
And strange enough, this didn't come from stick workers, it came from the students themselves.
The young people, the young people.
You and your friends?
Yes.
Who said, we wanted to go to these places, you know, that had bought us, you know, discriminated against us.
The main theory was the most visible place downtown. It was a place, and it was both, when I say visible, the interests were so stark, the differences.
The black interest was, you had to walk around the side of the theater down a dark alley, about 150 feet.
You woke up three fights of stairs and sitting about going to look at the theater.
So one night, 11 of us decided we were going to go to the front, entrusted to try to purchase tickets.
We stood there for about a half an hour and they wouldn't sell us tickets.
So we just stood there and then the police came finally.
And they asked us to disperse, we did not disperse the air, sitting with charge with this disorderly conduct and fighting an officer.
And it took us on a paddy wagon, took us off the jail.
The next morning we went to Kuwait and they released us on probation, which was a 90 day probation.
And being kids, we didn't realize that if you got arrested again, you couldn't be bailed out.
And nobody took the time to explain to us that because one week later, I was arrested again.
And all of us from the original group, from the original 11 were arrested again.
And as a part of another demonstration.
And at the same theater.
And immediately they singled us out the four of us who had previously arrested and they sent us to prison, to the Sumter County prison farm.
So you get arrested, you spend the night in jail, they pull you out immediately.
They put us in jail.
The next one we go back to court.
Same judge.
And they tell us that we have to immediately begin those sentences.
So at some point you realize, wait a minute, I'm about to do some time.
Yeah, exactly.
What are you thinking?
Well, we still been grasped that we wouldn't have to do this time.
We just felt as kids that somehow we were going to get out of this because there were two girls, two boys and two girls.
And so it happened overnight.
This is literally what they put us on the streets.
Well, the first day they took us, they put us in prison and took us out to do road work.
Cutting grasses and cutting grass and things like that.
Well, the local ministers went to City Hall and demanded, which was really something at its time, that they not put the women on the street, the girls on the streets.
So they did not.
My friend and I, the other guy, we decided to, we just sat down and sat and were not going to work.
So when we did that, they took the two of us down to the county jail, for the city of the county jail.
We put us in the Hole, which was about a four by six foot concrete enclosure, with a little sit at the bottom about 46 inches wide, where they would each day put in a piece of bread and a cup of water.
Well, we decided we weren't going to eat them on a hunger strike.
So we're total darkness for about seven days.
We did, we fasted for about seven days until we passed out.
Now, when you, in close proximity, was the other hole, were you together or were you accepting?
We got in the same hole.
And so they took us out of the hole and we were just literally passed out.
They took us to the hospital and filled us with some fluids and then we went back to the jail and we went back to work.
We went to work two days after that.
And the jobs that we did, ran some cutting grass on the side of the streets, picking up garbage on weekends.
The worst job was cleaning out the city switch.
They saved that specially for us.
None of the other prisoners had to do this, who were in all kinds of crimes, right?
You think these switch treatment plants, where they had these long pools?
Well, America's had three of them. I believe it was three.
And they would take us there with an armed guard.
And there was a dump truck that found us and it gave us two shovels.
And it cost all day to shovel out these pools of raw sewage, of sewage at the treatment plants.
I believe we did that maybe once a week, twice a week.
Maybe twice a week, yeah, twice a week, I believe something like that.
But that was very specifically for us because we were those no good-adgettakers.
And this is three months. I mean, you got 90 days, you're young.
You do. Your parents, they must be, you obviously worried.
What did they say?
Of course, my father was most visibly upset.
My mother was also upset. My father was just angry, I think.
As I said before, he never really, he was just fearful of my life.
And the fact that I had kind of disobeyed him and that you got in and got yourself in the trouble really now.
But they stood by me, they supported me, especially my mom.
She would bring things to her.
And then working on the street was different than other people who were just jailed.
I mean, no people, we're just incarcerated all the time.
So working on the street gave us an opportunity to have people pass us by to come by and they would see us working on the street.
And they would let us know what's going on in the movement.
They would give us money sometimes by things like that.
I started smoking cigarettes, cigarettes, cigarettes, things like that at that time.
Unfortunately, yeah, I was smoking.
But it was in kind of doing an outlet for us to get information.
It's the kind of freedom we get on the outside.
We would work all day long.
And in the day, they'd bring us back to the jail, say, don't lock us up at night.
And at night, we would watch other people who were arrested on the day being brought in.
And to see other people continuing to fight and to continue to demonstrate gave us really that's what got us through.
How did the jailer's treacher?
Well, the jailers were very racist, very, very cold, very...
Just no sympathy at all for what we were doing.
The sheriff of something kind with that time was the sheriff's chapel, where the whole was, where the best way they kept us in the whole.
He was the one who wanted (Dr.) King to refer to as a meanest man in the world after the king was jailed in this jail in 1961.
Had a reputation for just really beating up blacks for little or nothing.
And that was really the local police department at that time.
Just some very racist police department.
And had no tolerance for what we were doing at that time at all.
And what was the sheriff's name again?
Sheriff Fred Chappell.
He was probably...
I'm totally was the biggest bootlegger in the county as well.
But you could compare them to Jim Clark, Al Lingo, but Sheriff Fred Chappell was his name.
And how about the other inmates, those who weren't in for movement, activism?
How did they respond to you?
They responded very positively.
They were mostly older guys who oftentimes prays us for what we were doing.
And kind of acted as big brothers to us, you know, protected us.
If there was someone who wanted to harm us, you know, then they were quite, quite receptive to us.
And we looked upon them as...
And we were always about trying to enlighten them as well while we were in there.
We think that was an opportunity to bring them into the fold, you know, and to talk about the conditions on which they got the end of the first place.
To do some organizing.
Exactly.
A great place to organize.
It's a matter of fact.
You have a cap of bodies.
Exactly.
So you do your time.
You survive.
Yes.
You make it through.
What do you remember coming out?
Do you remember being released?
I do.
And no fanfare.
We were just simply released.
We did our time when we got out.
And but that's when I was even more committed to doing this work.
I began to...
That's when I...
I finished high school.
And then immediately after that I joined Stiggy.
And began to continue working throughout America.
But I also worked in other counties around the counties as well.
Continue doing voter registration.
Continue doing...
Testing the laws of the public, the combination of what have you.
I remember the night the Civil Rights Bill was signed.
We decided we were going to test it at a local restaurant.
This is July 64.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Myself and John Perdew, who I believe is here, who was one of the Americans for.
SNCC worker.
Bob Mants, out of Morehouse, who we've seen passed away.
And for the students, we went down to a place called the Hasty House restaurant.
And we sat there and we ordered...
We tried to order the food but the waiters never came.
One of us, one of the guys who we...
With us decided that he needed to go to the restroom.
And the restroom was outside.
He had to go outside and go around to the side of the building.
While we were waiting, no one came to take our order.
But about 10 minutes passed, we noticed that he hadn't come back from the restroom.
So we finally got up and sat to get up and leave.
And as we get up to leave to go to the car,
we met by a group of whites who would come across the street from a service station with tire irons.
And they had a lot of tire arms and...
And baseball bats.
And so they waited until we got into the car,
which was a convertible car.
And then they just ran out on the car with baseball bats and tires and beat us on top of our heads.
And we finally got the car started and we just...
We get out of there.
Without the guy who had gone to the restroom.
We talked about two days later.
And he said what happened was that when he went to the restroom, he was attacked.
And beaten.
And he just ran off and never came back.
And so...
But that was the first...
Even we decided to test the laws of public accommodation.
The Americas for.
This happens after...
And this was...
The Americas for was...
Before that, this was 63 years.
There was a demonstration.
In fact, again,
Slickhead felt that night demonstrations were really dangerous.
And sort of encouraged it not to do it.
But again, students took the lead.
And on this particular night,
they marched from the church where we had a mass meeting and was going downtown.
To demonstrate.
And as it happened, the workers,
St. Rookers were also downtown.
And that night, they unleashed dogs and water hoses on the demonstrators.
And people were arrested.
And they...
they keyed in on the SNCC workers.
And Don Harris, John Purdue,
there was a core worker, Zev Aelony.
And the four of them was Ralph Allen also from SNCC.
And charging with a century-old sedition law,
which carried the death penalty.
They stayed in jail, I believe, for about 84 days,
85 days.
And were finally released by a three-judge (federal) panel.
The significance of that...
If the state had prevailed on those charges,
it would have stifled movements all around the country.
Because it meant that the police had the right to detain,
arrested detained workers without cause.
And put them in jail.
And so the legal team was a team that included C.B. King of Albany.
Donald Hollowell, like Atlanta,
Constance Baker, Martin Lee, was on the team.
Another lawyer out of Macon, Georgia,
I believe Larry Thompson, I believe, was his name.
And they won that case.
So it was very significant in that they prevailed.
And it provided even more strength for people to move forward in the movement.
Would you remember hearing about them possibly facing execution?
That possibility was always on people's mind.
Because we knew that the power structure as it was was determined to do all in its power
to curtail any movement activity.
And so that possibility never left us.
But we just felt confident that people were not going to let this go.
That people were willing to get onto the streets and protests and demand
that these people be released.
We were helpful in getting a nationwide movement
to build groups across the country from college campuses,
legal groups across the country to write letters of protest.
There was massive fundraising for that benefit.
And so we were encouraged by the output of that support.
And we knew that the more support we got,
the more that the nation turned its eyes on this particular case
that we would be successful.
So we were confident that they were going to be released at some point.
And in the case, the case worked as way all the way to the Supreme Court.
Exactly.
Do you remember hearing when word came down that the court had upheld the lower court ruling
from not mistaken that Georgia can't do this?
Exactly.
Yes. Of course, we were all jubilant.
I have photos that we've collected from our collective sense stand of
the jubilant faces as they were released upon their release.
The interesting thing now is that the courthouse where they were tried
is where we now have our display of memorabilia from that movement from that time.
That's where the welcome center is now.
It was the fellow courthouse at that time.
Then became a post office and now it's a welcome center.
That's an interesting turn around.
Certainly when people think about America as they think about the Americas for.
But they also think about those young girls who were demonstrating in America's
and then wind up in the Leesburg stockade.
Could you tell us how that occurred, what happened there?
As more and more people got into the streets and demonstrated that jails became full.
We filled the Americas city jails so they began looking around the county for
alternate locations so they could house people.
There were several abandoned prison camps that were made available to them.
There were people of jail not only We filled the jails in Americus the city jail, the county jails.
Then they started taking people out to places like Terrell County.
People were jailed there.
They took people to the Leesburg, Georgia, the Leesburg stockade.
I wouldn't make Leesburg significant with that.
Leesburg's where the juvenile girls were taken.
Those under 16 years of age.
It was an abandoned prison camp.
No bedding, all concrete, no shower facilities.
One toilet for some 35 to 40 young girls.
On one occasion one of the guards threw a rattlesnake into the whole den area.
They began screaming and one of the guards came and said, you know, pretended that he didn't know that there was no stake in there.
Then one of the guards let all the girls out so they could look for the snakes supposedly.
As it turned out one of the guards went and found the state and picked it up.
We were told later on by some of the girls who were housed in there.
This guy picked the stink up like he knew it was his pet.
There were times when there were white men who would drive up to the jail.
They knew they were housed there.
They would try to get the guards to convince them to let them go inside and have what they say.
Have some fun with the girls.
Young girls.
It was a classic case of the inhumanity that these people were willing to place on young girls.
And Lee's Brooks located could have known that.
So much so that people like SS Magazine did a story on it a few years ago on that episode.
They would call the stolen girls because the way they wanted the police burst in the middle of the night
the police brought a tractor trailer up to the jail.
And one by one they were hooded into the back of the tractor trailer in the middle of the night and taken to this place in the dark.
They had no idea where they were going.
And it was days later, maybe more than a week later, that the parents knew they didn't know where they were.
Nobody knew where they were.
So that's why the stolen girls were given to them.
And so that's what made the story even more compelling and more significant.
That they would do this to young juveniles.
And that was the real significance of that particular hold in place.
Were you all looking for them?
I mean, you all didn't know where they were either.
Well, I was in constant, I was in jail at the time myself.
But of course, parents were trying to get information.
And eventually they found out what they were doing and what happened.
But they literally didn't know what they were until later on.
In addition to the direct action work, the citizens and the demonstrations,
you also do a voter registration work.
And canvassing and the life where there are other activities as well that you work specifically involved in with SNCC during that time.
So 64 and moving into 65.
It's all about organizing.
There wasn't a time when President domestic workers were being threatened,
if any of that children were involved in any movement activity, some were fired.
And so we began a, along with some of the domestic workers, they formed a Maids Union.
What was this?
This was in 6465.
And these women got together and decided they wanted to ask for the men better wages,
those who were still employed.
And so the first Maze Union was formed by the mother of several of the young girls who had been incarcerated.
So we organized things like, we have to organize things like that.
We also set up a library because at the time we couldn't use a local library.
We organized a national campaign to get schools around the country to donate books to America.
At one time we had about 20,000 books thrown into America from places around the country.
And we set up our own library, what was called the U-Center here at America's.
Before that was called the Colored Hospital back in the 40s and 50s,
which trained black doctors.
And in fact at one time this particular facility trained more black doctors in any place in the country.
In the 40s and 50s that building still stands and it went on the national historic registry,
I believe about four or five years ago.
So we continued to do things like that to organize Maze unions.
We formed a quilting union of women quilters.
And these were all of the people who could support themselves in case they were fried, you know,
leave their jobs and what have you.
And of course, the crux of all this was voter registration and voter registration.
We were always trying to mobilize people to run for office.
And along with that voter registration was key in terms of getting people registered and getting registered to support those candidates.
So it was an ongoing work, but that was really the major focus registered people to vote.
In connected with that, I mean there is another case that comes out of America's that has to do with,
I mean at the time although people are trying to register, you still have segregated lines.
And the life, could you say a little bit about that?
Mary Kate Bell Fishbel was the first woman to qualify for the Democratic primary in some of the counties.
She ran for office of Justice of the Peace.
And what years is this?
This was 1965.
On the dearly election, as people were voting, she and three other women,
Mamie Campbell, who was the wife of the America's movement president, Reverend Robert Campbell,
Gloria Wise, who is now deceased and Lena Turner, who lives in Atlantic City,
they decided to try to vote in the white voting line.
When they refused to leave, they were all arrested, put in jail.
And that led to a daily deluge of demonstrations, protests, demand in their release.
These demonstrations went on every day.
And during that time there were several confrontations with the police,
several people were beating, throwing in jail.
One day the white merchants of the city decided to get together,
and this was about maybe three or four days after they had been arrested.
The merchants got together and decided they were going to bond the women out of jail.
The white merchants?
The white merchants, because they feared more trouble, more, as they call it,
more confrontation in the streets.
So faced with that, the women decided that we're not going to accept it.
They wrote a letter which we have and now we now have that letter and I request that we've been keeping.
And it says simply that these are the same merchants they've stood by.
It's black kids, boys and girls were beaten and assaulted for simply trying to demonstrate
their rights.
And now you've come forward to bond us out of jail and they cite hypocrisy of them,
not speaking out then, but one debond us out, simply to keep quiet and what have you.
So they refused to bond, they stayed in jail.
And about a week later they were released, federal judge released them,
unconditionally, dropped the charges and what have you.
And declared that segregated voting lines in Sumter,
so that was significant.
A significant victory that really propelled more people who saw power in their numbers.
And so each victory was one that really unified us and swelled the numbers in terms of people
willing to get out there and protest.
And you were with the America's movement for up and two and through 1966.
Yeah, 1966, that's correct.
And then you head down to Mississippi to Tougaloo.
Head to Mississippi.
What happened was that SNCC had started a program of providing scholarship money for kids
who weren't you go to school, provided that you come back to your community and do some work,
continue doing some work.
And so I jumped at the opportunity, I didn't know anything about Tougaloo.
I just knew other stick people who were up in Mississippi, you know.
Went to Mississippi, went to Tougaloo, had planned the major in social sociology.
Got the campus and recognized that Tougaloo was had been at the forefront of a lot of civil rights activity in Mississippi.
And at that time, Tougaloo, to my knowledge had the only was the only Black institution [actively] protesting the (war in.
And so I joined that movement and became very involved in activities there in Mississippi.
Later on went to places like Greenville, working with a sharp opposite what have you, things like that.
I left there after two years because most of my time I've been spent actually as an activist off campus.
It was difficult to really settle in as a student after having gone through what happened in America
and seeing the conditions that in a lot of places simply were not changing.
And there was more work to be done.
So once you become an activist, you don't settle down anymore, you continue it.
And to this day, you know, you want to be in the fight, you know, somehow.
There was no going back.
No going back, never going back.
And so after you leave Tougaloo, what do you do after that?
I, while it took a little, I met, there was a lawyer who was from America's who had been run out of America
and a white lawyer who was forced to flee America's because he had been sympathetic to the movement.
His name was Warren Fortson.
His brother at the time happened to be Ben Fortson, who was Secretary of State in Atlanta.
Well, Forson had, was head of the America School Board at that time, I believe,
and had fought to integrate the library here in America's.
The thing that really pushed him over the age and where the white community was the fact that he,
there were two students who had been arrested, born a girl.
One was the first student, one of the first students to integrate the white high school,
Roberta Freeman, and her boyfriend.
They were at Parking one night, as kids, you know.
And so the policeman pulled up alongside them and decided to charge them with,
and these were an exposure, fornication, what had he, and arrested them.
Now, we feel that this was brought on by the fact that she had integrated in America's high,
and she was doing it gradually.
And we feel that they put these charges on them to keep her from being the first black to graduate from America's high.
Well, Forson was, he took that case on, and he defended them in court, successfully.
But he was never able to live in the city after that.
He was hounded by the Ku Klux Klan. His own neighbors turned against him.
People he had gone to church with turned against him.
He was afraid to sit by his window at night because of threats.
So he has finally moved to Atlanta.
And so, fast forward to 67, 68.
I'm at a lecture at Tugulu, and Forson happens to be there.
And I see him, and we speak to each other, and we connect.
And so I tell him that I'm going to be leaving to Luprace and going back to America.
So he said, what are you going to do? I said, well, I don't know.
So he said, why don't you go back to Atlanta and see my brother?
I'll call my brother and tell him that you're looking for some work.
So I get back to Atlanta, and I go to the Secretary of State's office.
And he sends me to the Georgia Department of Archives, which is on the Secretary of State's office.
And I go in there, and I take a job as an apprentice in paper conservation, restoration.
And I learned the craft, and I wound up standing there for about 15 years.
Well, 12 or 15 years, actually.
But before I left there, I began to study photography and began to take photographs,
and I opened up an art gallery while I was still working here.
Moving in that gallery?
Ancestral Art Gallery.
And when I felt comfortable enough, I resigned the job and I left and did the gallery full time.
And I think being in the movement prepared me for that, because I'd always been intrigued by images.
And of course being in the movement, a lot of times it was only images that propelled people, signs that were made, photographs that were taken.
And so I began to do that as a street photographer.
And I grew up in the movement of images by other artists as well.
But that was a way of continuing that to this and because it allowed me to elevate the work of African American artists who didn't have venues for the most part in places like Atlanta.
Whose work was had been diminished by traditional, you know, outbursts, galleries and what have you.
And marginalized, you know, so that led me to another form of activism in terms of trying to project the arts more positively than the African American community.
And it was a place where people could come.
It was not just a gallery to buy art, but it was a place where people could come to be informed.
We had poetry sessions there.
We had public meetings there.
They had to do with things in terms of in the community.
So it was an outlet to continue that activism, but in a different, you know, a different way.
I want to wrap up in a second by talking about the American movement, remember it.
I want to go back just quickly, just briefly if we can.
And ask you about you were working, you were engaged in anti-war protests.
But then you were drafted.
I was drafted. Yes. In fact, that's, I was never, I was drafted in 69.
And when I went into the military, I had basic training at Fort Benning, Georgia, which was hours drive from a hometown.
Where most people go on to advance training when you finish basic, they kept me there at Fort Benning.
They never gave me a security clearance.
And they said it was because of my arrest record in America.
So instead of sending me on to an advanced training, they sent me into what was called a hold of a company (?).
And with that meant, with that means is that it's a company where all you do is duty work.
You dig ditches, you cut grass, you clean the trees, bathrooms, and what have you for the offices and what have you.
It was a place where, during this time, it was common for people who had been gotten arrested during the Vietnam War.
They gave you choice of either going to prison or going to the war.
So here I was in this group.
And they literally woke you up every morning at 6.30 and you had a duties to do.
It would be digging ditches, they cut grass.
In fact, one of the duties was to build an archery course for the offices, which literally go into this jungle like wood, wooded area.
And dig highways through and cut highways through to dig up and set up these targets.
And it was another form of punishment, you know.
I did that for a whole year.
And at the end of the year, someone decided they were going to close a training camp at Fort Benning.
So they closed on a training camp, the center.
And so if everybody either got shipped to Vietnam or Germany, I got sent to Germany.
I still didn't have a security clearance.
They gave me an MOS, they gave me a duty, which was clerk type, is just the name.
And so they sent me to Europe to what was called a material command, about a five hour drive from Paris, France.
They literally put me in an office behind a big office, but in the back.
But then there's going to cheer.
And I sent there all day long.
I did nothing.
So what I did in my time was that I picked up a camera.
That was when I first picked up the camera.
I used my weekends. I bought a car from a guy who was coming back to the States, paid him 100 bucks for a car.
And I would take off on weekends, drive to the countryside, drive to Paris, a six hour drive, five hour drive.
And I spent all my time doing that.
But for the rest of that, my service time.
And 71 I was released in New Jersey.
And then I came back and went back to work at the State Archives.
And so you sort of migrated back to a certain extent to America's.
Because now you're spearheading this effort to keep the America's movement alive on the minds and in the memories of people.
That is correct.
And 2007, myself and several other veterans of the Americas movement decided to convene on America's once again to.
Because one of the things we recognize as movement veterans is that a lot of us hadn't passed on these stories to our kids.
And we don't have no idea what some of the parents had been through.
A lot of the history had been lost, a lot of these significant things that we talked about in terms of the Americas for.
And the women who were arrested for trying to vote.
All of this was going to be lost if we didn't take up the mantle and try to collect this information and put it out there.
So we met in America's in 2007.
We met at a place which was around zero.
A place called Bottoms funeral home.
It was one of the places where we would feel a director who and his whole family had allowed us to use this place for a meeting place.
He was the sole bail bondsman for the Americas movement.
People got arrested. He was the only bondsman who could bail for us.
We went back there and met his daughter who was also incarcerated at Leesburg, who's now the director of the funeral home there.
She allowed us to come there and be back once again.
And we decided that every two years we would want to have a tribute.
But in a long range ago it was to somehow either bill or constitute a museum there, but the housing materials that we had begun to collect.
And we were all about the business of collecting photographs, some of us had kept things from that time.
Flyers, we had formed a newsletter among the simmers at that time.
And we published a newsletter out of the SNCC House with an old memory graph machine.
It was called the Voice of Americus in Southwest Georgia.
It was a six page mimeograph that, and we assigned people as reporters, you know, we have people going to other counties here reporting on what happened in this county.
We have copies of those (Voice of Americus issues) that we kept in our archives.
And so that was a long range mission.
The other niches we had to do with trying to provide scholarships for kids who were doing things today in that community service things in that community.
We have started a mentoring program of kids trying to get adults to mentor kids who we see falling through the cracks, you know.
That mission has led us a lot of different paths.
We are connecting with the grandkids of some of the veterans of the movement who had no idea that that parents were involved.
Fascinating thing is that each celebration we bring out the photographs and we went through all the newspapers that covered the Americus Movement.
(Americus) Times-Recorder literally did no reporting because it didn't work to get out.
But papers like Atlanta Journal, Columbus Ledger-Enquirer-Enquirer, Macon Telegraph, Atlanta Daily World.
We come through their archives and we reproduce photographs, I mean, the news articles, photographs.
And we, it's a very kind of a crew display because we just blew it up with what we had.
Xerox machine, at some point we want to get these things digitized and then they can have better presentation.
But we have these four by six frame pieces that we display every celebration.
And on one occasion we had a young lady walk through the, and she was looking at the photographs.
She saw a picture of a woman who was pregnant.
And she said, that's my mother.
Okay, and that's me and her belly.
So her mother had not told her what she had done.
And she just literally went well at that time because she had no idea that her mother was one of those foot soldiers at that time.
So it's those things like that that propels you even more to know that the work you're doing is important.
We are committed to, to, to, to, to send this project to, to fruition.
We're trying to make some connections with the local university there who want to help us with our oral history project.
And hopefully other things will come as a result, as also as well.
This happens to be Jimmy Carter of Alma Mater as well in America, sir.
So it's not just about, it is about, very much about remembering the movement, but it's also about keeping the spirit of the movement.
Exactly.
A lot.
It's, we want to, in fact, the whole idea of the scholarship is to nurture a whole new generation of young activists to get them to see that they stand on the shoulders of some people who just made some tremendous miscyclophages.
And we want them to know that, that, that this work has to go on and it won't only go on if they take initiative and, and take the lead.
And, because of the times we pass to them.
And so we, we expect them to do it, you know.
It's expected of them to do that.
And so that's, that's been our mission. Every, every two years we, we do that.
Sam Mahon, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.